[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the most interesting
phenomenons of human beings
is our creativity, right?
I mean our ability to transform
the world, our ability
to imagine new
possibilities, our ability
to probe the perimeters
of possibility,
remix the present to see
into the adjacent possible,
which Steven Johnson refers to
as a shadow future that hovers
over the present
state of things,
a map of all the ways in
which the present can reinvent
itself.
Creativity is just connecting
things, as Steve Jobs says.
And people who go into this
creative zone, virtuosos
of the imagination, those
ecstatic technicians
of the sacred spaces
of human virtuosity,
athletes when they get into the
zone, scientists when they have
their eureka moments, musicians,
artists, when they enter
these flow states, jazz
musicians when they're
improving, Charlie Mingus as he
rhapsodizes through a tumbling
thicket of ideas with such
a sharp and vital alacrity
that it can take
the breath away.
These flow states
are finally starting
to be understood,
thanks to neuroscience.
The part of the brain
responsible for self-editing
literally goes dim.
So there is this thing, a kind
of scrambling of the self.
There is a scrambling
of the super ego that's
trying to correct
everything you do
and sensor and filter
what is otherwise
collective subconscious--
active imagination, so to speak.
And I think that these
artists, these athletes, when
they go into the flow
state, I'm sure that they've
had their 10,000 hours
of practice in whatever
their skill is, but then
they go into that flow state.
Perfection is not
just about control.
It's also about letting go.
They shut down their
lateral prefrontal cortex
and they enter the realm
of the numinous, the realm
of the imaginal, the realm
where the dream becomes real.
That space, that
head space of flow
is the place where
dreams are born.
[MUSIC PLAYING]